it's funny because I haven't got the
part my obviously every girl wants to be
a princess I mean ever since you're a
kid and a Disney Princess and Cinderella
is kind of if I say it's like too much
to really even believe even though while
halfway through filming and it's all
happening but so yeah obviously that
kind of idea of being a princess is just
magical and then on top of that actually
working on the film with Ken and with
everyone the essence of who she is and
that's like a dream role too because
it's she's so special and kind and
unique and and so it's been really just
playing her regardless of the fact that
she's been a princess has been a real
dream role yeah I read all the different
versions of the fairy tale and of the
story and of the myth so there's a lot a
lot to go on but but I think something
that was really important for me was it
that it wasn't just this abstract sense
of goodness it wasn't this girl that's
just good and kind and sweet it's it's
so much more than that and why is she
and looked a lot into like spirituality
and and you know like Gandhi and people
that are able to have found this way of
living in the moment in the now and in
and able to just deal with life in her
in a way that I know I can I struggle to
and so I wanted to make it real not just
to kind of not just playing that that
state so in order to do that like
backstory and and everything to do with
my family and how I grew up and was kind
of essential for me it's not that he
just comes into sweeps her off her feet
it's very like an equal meeting I think
of two people so that's a bit different
from the animation I think it's not
about since Indra just being rescued by
a man it's about you know that okay he
happens to be a friend so you have is
that the castle but they're really
perfect for one another and they'll
they'll they
hold that they then treasure that have
courage and being be kind together and
you imagine that they're going to be
very very very happy together
I think the prince learned a lot from
Cinderella in fact and I think that it's
been written really cleverly in that
sense because you see that he's
challenged him and he's changed how he
thinks so much so that he is willing to
sort of defy the king and defy the Duke
and to hold this ball to find her I mean
it's a serious act of love and of faith
in this girl he's met
you